17 scrubs well brushes put my socks on
who's the better receiver sitting right
here think about it
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome the sims and left go sims the
Oracle you were in fine form this past
week thank you I'll be honest
social was blowing up well Sam's bortles
has been portals as benched I think they
want to know yeah did you take joy in it
were you sitting at home going well a
little because I want to go like see
like listen to what I say you know I
don't sit around and just twiddle my
thumbs and watch football you know I
study it hard yeah so but I'm never
happy to see a guy lose his job I've
been there before I've been benched I
understand that but at the same time I
feel like some people are starting to
finally see some of the flaws that I've
been trying to point out to people for
the last two years you and I both know
since this started last season because
we saw how talented Jacksonville was
loved the Jag will have a man crush on
more guys on the Jaguars than any other
team in the sport bortles is going to
start against the Eagles in London right
decision you mentioned that it's the
problem of the team yes Sims and left go
is about solutions we are not problems
and I believe there's something in the
air that can fix this love
[Music]
so the relationship between the Jaguars
and bortles off to a little bit of a
rocky patch right I found an app yeah
it's a good dating app sure it's called
Cuba Cuba Oh matching up cubies Oh teams
that need them I wouldn't trust you to
matchmake anything go I have some steamy
ones rice in a corset hot and heavy
right first one Baltimore Maryland I
think a perfect match for Jacksonville
rg3 no no it doesn't work swipe the
wrong way I don't know what to say they
already have two quarterbacks why not
let him go they don't trust Lamar
Jackson to run the full scope of the
offense yet the Baltimore Ravens look at
themselves as a team that can go to the
Super Bowl they are not gonna trade away
rg3 because they if just something
happens to Joe Flacco rg3 is gonna be
the guy that comes in to run the offense
this one's got an interesting screen
name Gump man five twenty five years old
in a relationship New Orleans moved a
little bit so willing to move again oh
okay
Teddy Bridgewater oh it's the most
coveted backup of all back oh that's
right yep got taste some Hill oh oh
that's right taste some Hill who we
haven't seen really throw the ball you
need to he's in chronic as if he is that
he might be down the line but again
sorry Jacksonville New Orleans is not
gonna risk their chance to go to the
Super Bowl with Drew Brees getting a
high ankle sprain or getting hurt that's
why they traded for Teddy Bridgewater
before this season Jacksonville before
this season all right this one is
spontaneous creative what
ivy-league-educated right fits magic
okay if it's Patrick come on there's a
glimmer there might wanna like save hot
tab okay or something like I save that
tab like you know I don't know a tap on
the computer something next one is a
little vulnerable right now right
recently got out of a three-year
relationship at a buffalo yeah didn't
really work out and the small little
rebound and cherylin right
Tyrod Taylor that is the kind of
quarterback that makes sense in this
situation like Tampa Bay where there's a
third string or do they go okay we got
somebody here where our team won't fall
apart if the if the
if the starter goes down okay all these
people wrapped up in relationships I
have one that is single ooh and I it's
one of those profiles to look at and go
I don't understand why they haven't been
scooped up yeah I know where you're
going already I don't know if you do
yeah little-known player I bet Colin
Kaepernick oh yeah I never heard of him
yeah yeah I mean hey listen you know
where I stand in this argument he should
have been a starting quarterback last
year should they bring in Kaepernick
just to see how he does just that
question should they bring in just to
see what level he's at sure knit their
duty I don't want to win the Super Bowl
isn't it their job to go let's just see
the point is this this is not running
back or receiver or defensive back where
they just go run to that hole or cover
that guy this is about learning the
whole offense and learning all these
rules and to ask a quarterback to come
in at this point of the year and then
just take over and learn off the whole
system it's kind of unrealistic that's
why we don't see it really ever happen
the jaguars and a quarterback
looks like we're unable to find a match
at this time right but I would argue
there is not a better match than Terrell
Owens and Chad Johnson and there are as
human right I'm thinking the year maybe
2004 2005 okay football season as a team
as a you speed I bet that's Doug
what gold a gold shoe around you told me
go up here yeah it's awesome
I'm gonna get McDonough's after this
who's the better receivers him right
here
think about it who's the better receiver
yeah well I think Theo is one of the top
three receivers in the history of the
sport that's a lie let me tell you why
well tell me what he's not the better
receiver he had the better cards dealt
to him and took advantage of those
opportunities
I'm gonna make you stop right this
because I only play with Steve yellow
three years Oh Steve you on three years
that's it I don't care we play outside
of it you have a person you have Carson
please a Heisman Trophy late for the 49
that's nothing good these are awesome
organizations right according to
everybody else and I made the most of
the car that I was right so really what
ideas don't tell you even is talking I
played with the Buffalo Bills
I'm nothing and cut off that's enough
enough played my Cincinnati baby with
you
was there one part of the game anything
part of the game that you stole from
each other where you were like damn
couldn't I couldn't do anything he did
it honestly his DNA is makeup his skill
set is completely I mean night and day
yeah completely the stuff he would do
the stiff arm in people never worked
I don't go to obviously because my I was
more of a finesse player this is my
favorite thing to watch tio do yeah him
and Brandon Marshall dudes playing bump
and run let's say I'm tired fourth
quarter they had this in tugging pool
where they invite the contact I wait for
you to get a hold and pull by how in the
yeah I know I tried you to practice one
time yeah I'm right there in the same
spot so you're on the Bengals what was
the day when he joined the Bengals
hi hey lobby for that big time with
Marvin but what Marvin I said I asked
Marvin you know a lot maybe we really
need to bring T in I
think it would help us offensively
tremendously who was your receiver coach
god bless his soul here my shepherd
I accept at a time dealing with you two
in meetings must've been amazing I would
have loved them it is easy to what not
when I'm working we unlocked the air and
the air I know you both are it was it I
mean again people may think that we're
uncomfortable based on the antics and
how we you know go about but when it
came to football like literally that's
what nobody gets to see in the in the
workplace when it's time to work I
remember he gave me to slow down on
Friday remember
yeah man Fridays yeah I'm out there
Fridays are you know it goes the
chilliest I'm the tapered I know you
else I know right man listen do tissue
teams later boy hoping I'm taking a
scout team yeah this is way into my
tenth ninth year I'm just out there
moving
yeah the perceptions I remember just I'm
just growing up think about the
hurricane to the nineties yeah and
that's what I grew up watching so as a
kid growing up it was the game of
football was about having fun when
you're knitting it fill and you
misbehavior they do something you don't
like or you don't you don't follow their
rules what's the first let me take from
you money your money because that's what
they think you value the most but for me
the money was gonna come money go go
regardless yeah which is why I never
stopped doing what I was learning
because the money was great it was
awesome but when I didn't have any money
this is the way I played the game of
football which is why I never stopped
even with the go step further you talk
about the Hall of Fame and everybody
realizes when you're in the Hall of Fame
obviously there financial opportunities
well outside of that and so I was well
or well a well aware of that and I had
some Hall of Famers even told me there's
a man you're gonna mess up these
opportunities you know for me I'm just
like Chad you know money comes and goes
and if I had to you know if I'm put in a
situation where I gotta choose money
over my family and friends
i'ma choose my family and friends all
day and it was just it was sad to see
how the media again they didn't they
didn't allow themselves an opportunity
to know who
or who we are as people and they went
into the perception of who they thought
we were and again we just went out there
with you it makes it more into game it
makes it more interesting they have
their villains they have someone to talk
about there has to be there has to be a
bad costume you know but they had to but
it's unfair like you said because again
it's it's you how can you justify Tom
Brady doing or saying some of the same
things that I've done right so any
motion right right and he's word of the
stands never seen him curse out which is
I've seen in berate his own teammate
but he's looked at an upon as a leader a
champion you know if I if I had to do it
again honestly the restart and had to do
it and added to it the exact same way
the wind changed so tío just surprised
us right like we were hanging out with
Chad Johnson in comes t oh those two are
really like brothers oh I thought he
came because he was like damn Sims is
there like let me go hang out with it
I'm pretty sure that's why I came by
you think so I think so I'm pretty cool
that's great we'll see that's the truth
he believes what he's saying it's not
really honest and sometimes we hear
coaches talk and we go that's not the
truth huh so it's time for a little bit
of coach speak alright Sims first one
you're doing it my rome comes out and
says I did it to try and get a spark
from this team to put everyone on notice
that's the reason he benched portals
right what's the truth the truth is
hahaha the old the old spark the team by
bench and the quarterback trick think
they bought that one I mean come on you
guys are watching the game this guy
can't throw the football what am I
supposed to do
no wonder nobody wanted this job when
they first tried to hire me alright so
rabl went for two at the end of the game
against the charger yes and after the
game he said you know put a lot of faith
into our players face the same situation
I like to think I'd do it the same way
what do you really wanted to say is hey
guys here's the truth I'm a linebacker
and I think like a linebacker I put two
fingers in the air and I say get me the
win
did I want a slant from Mariota at the 1
no my OC what are you doing you got a
mobile quarterback in Derrick Henry
figure it out
alright variable Doug Peterson my coach
of my Eagles man he looks teary-eyed
photo same pressures off man we can go
and play and have fun and just relax but
what he's really thinking is let's go we
want a Super Bowl now I'm losing control
of everything at Garza wins can't do it
all by himself my defects fall apart so
that took a lot out of oh it should have
that one was a little personal I liked
it so last week we said that every coach
should really wonder what would Bill
Belichick do and we made bracelets
WW BBD what would Bill Belichick do and
and we have letters here for all the
coaches the NFL so if it's time
management issue if it's salary if it's
comments put one in there for Doug
Marrone you okay yes we're gonna send
these to all the coaches the NFL so that
they ever reach a point where they don't
know what to do they can ask themselves
what would Bella you're so nice we're so
giving here at the Simpson left coach
yeah I'm not gonna lie I wore this home
right and this morning I took a shower
and I'm getting ready for work tonight
and it actually made me uncomfortable
yeah cuz I thought about how would Bill
Belichick shower right and I literally
took it off better than 17 scrubs
well brushes put my socks on it freaked
me out like it legitimately freaked me
out
yeah I mean he's a machine there's no
doubt about it
hi I'm Peyton Manning and you're
watching Sims and left go on bleacher
report
I don't love it but you will we are not
even halfway through the NFL season yet
but you believe there are four teams
that have already punched their ticket
yes to get a bye in the first run the
plows you believe the top two seats in
the NFC AFC it's already sewn up
finito it's not even a patch your mouth
finito great but it's not even week
eight yet yeah that's okay I'm good at
this aren't so who the Rams the onesie
lock it in okay the Saints the to seat
lock it in no other team could come and
take a spot I don't see it I think
they're a cut above the rest of the NFC
what about the air the AFC first round
by Kansas City Chiefs first round by New
England Patriots lock it in hundred
percent yes they are the camera the top
in that conference no doubt staple left
cola Oracle guarantee
or a crated and permanent marker write
it in permanent ink alright seems you
sitting
I said ink yeah that'd bro you like him
NFC AFC looks good man it really does
thanks bro
it's just I'm a little scared of the
Vikings at Kirk Cousins dude you can't
do this I just got this done they got
lasers man we can always update them
it's like Power Rankings you're all good
we've got ourselves a winner Tony the
dragon nailed the Broncos last week I'm
gonna be honest I don't think he
actually watched the game but it doesn't
matter because the dragon is alive and
well this week the revenge of Brock
tober taken on his old Texans let's see
who Tony takes
you smell that smells good I hate that
smell good it's also the smell of
success why Tony because the Broncos won
I have one hundred and thirteen dollars
and sixty-five cents that's great thank
you very much yeah you watch the game
though right oh yes of course I did and
you felt good
they blow him out that was great game I
was sitting there calling the dragon
yeah
all right so this Thursday the four and
three Miami Dolphins with Brock Osweiler
head to Houston the four and three
Texans and deshaun Watson I like to pick
Texas already you do yes just by that
display that it's a big favorite though
Tony it's seven and a half point seven I
have poison you're gonna do another 250
of my dollars cuz I'd like to come back
next week yeah I want you to come back
next week
final answer I think the Gulf is oh I
really wanted you to take the Texas you
did yeah but now you've already said it
so you're going dolphins don't these
other wait let me get a Dolphins don't
leave me hanging dolphins dolphins so
the dragon and I tried to convince him
not to after the shoot oh do you touch
my dragon I have him trained the way I
would like to train though you agree
with yes I do
Wow what are we listening wrong Wyler
against the defense that's gonna want
revenge oh I know revenge I know it's
too many points on the road yes I don't
think they're gonna win the game but
they're gonna cover the spread
all right was it drag if you watched
Monday Night Football you may have seen
this kid dressed up like Odell Beckham
jr. what a cutie and it gave us the idea
for Simms and left go next week is
Halloween yeah I want to see more kids
dressed up as players or coaches the NFL
I mean I want pictures like this that's
the classic right there I mean actual
life-size cheeks there for Andy Reid
he's even doing the same thing with his
eyes that Andy does when he looks at the
place sheet or little dick out dick guy
I love the vest that is unbelievable the
mustache looks real who wins in a fight
hurricane Ditka Ditka I'm taking this
cab home a dick guy so send us a picture
of video of your kid dressed up like a
player-coach hashtag NFL kids
we will put them on the show next week
for Halloween and your son is gonna be
dressing up as Phil Simms Chris Simms
nope he's going with Thanos this year
the villain he's still in shock that the
Avengers lost said that was a that was
groundbreaking dressing up a stand-up
man else is kind of cool my little
girl's gonna be a farmer but she's gonna
be don't allow us to tell you thanks for
participating in hashtag NFL kids Chris
sorry you didn't tell me until today too
late for Simms he's out homey
I am the lef koe man and we will holler
at you next week enjoy the games
everybody I'm definitely faster than he
is he's quicker right he's quicker we
can go out there base right now we have
cameras it does not wonder Street is
there I really explained out in the
middle of the street we can hang on 16:1
blow your nose up and Tita makes yeah
blow your nose on it so I'm gonna say
one you're wearing jeans he's a tech
stretch from H&M hey what's up homies
thanks for watching subscribe to the be
our YouTube channel man you're such a
millennial also while you're here we
have a lot other videos check them out
and then what time does our show come
out Wednesday 8:00 p.m. be there or be
square
he ruined it it was really close